[Music]
you talk about how you're traveling
around at least tell me you're they're
flying you around are you are you taking
advantage of the perks when you travel
you go tonight
they must be putting up a nice hotels
you taking care of yourself all right so
a pedicure manicure you know I don't do
any of that stuff and I went to a spa
once with my we're on vacation me and
the kids and my wife and my daughter we
going to the spa my wife's like you're
so stressed honey why don't you get out
and get a massage I'm like I don't
really want to get a massage but I'll go
down and I'll use the steam room so they
went to get like you know facials and
stuff and I go into the to the you know
men's locker room and I and I put a
towel on and I go through this door
where I think the steam room is and
there's like this pool there but I got a
small pool you know like a round thing
and it was all bubbly and hot like a hot
tub and I'm not a hot tub guy but there
was nobody there and I figured this is
great and it actually had a sign it said
tranquility pool and I'm like all right
could use some tranquility yeah so I get
into thing it's really like the waters
like you know bubbly and stuff
right cuz it's got they have jets in
there sure so I get in and it's nice and
I didn't realize how many Jets they were
they were coming at all angles now one
of the Jets caught you I guess you've
taken off the towel at this point oh
yeah I'm naked okay completely naked and
can I say I don't know if I could say
this you guys pretty much say whatever
you want that table okay I'll go for it
all right I'm in the thing and one of
the jet streams hits me in the taint
okay
no I didn't know I didn't know you can't
say that be clear with me another word
where else would I describe that part of
the body and hit you right in your
tranquillity I don't know about you
Conan but when I get hit in the tank
with a with a with a jet stream
apparently what happens is I get an
erection so now I'm in there with you
every step of the way
I'm gonna be honest with you guys it
felt so good and I was by myself I
thought I'm just gonna do this for a
while yeah and I'm just sitting there
like this is unbelievable I'm gonna let
the and then I'm just sitting there with
the jet stream hitting and I'm kind of
smiling and the door over there opens
and two ladies walking in bathing suit
this is an immense unisex Africa great
quility pool right and I have a giant
erection and there's these very
attractive women in their 30s they come
into the tranquility pulley sit right
there and they start talking now I'm
like what am I gonna do now they can't
see because the water's all bubbling on
top right so automatic I just closed my
eye so I'm not looking at them and I
just got to get rid of the erection and
that's what I'm doing for a while
meanwhile they won't stop talking and I
realize like I have no way out of here
until they stop talking right cuz even
without the erection I'm not getting up
and walking out I'd rather get out with
the erection than without yeah
[Applause]
but I see your point yeah you'd rather
just not have to face that wanna guys I
thought they did they talked for a while
get they talked for like 45 minutes and
at that point I was literally like a
giant Irish prune at that point right
and then I heard one of the one we got
excuse me are you an actor and I'm like
oh my god in my head I'm like no I'm not
how do I get out of this how do I get
out of this and then I was like wait a
minute this is my opening and I
literally you know pulled a Dafoe card I
said yes I am
Willem Dafoe
I'd read that about
[Applause]